You can't me listen people, this is like
a this is a mindset issue. You can't
mess around with your chemistry like
this. You can't play around with these
things. You can't play around with your
body's biochemistry and um expect and
not expect to pay the price for it.
Especially chemistry, especially a
chemistry that is so intimately involved
with growth. They suppress the appetite,
which sounds like it's a good thing,
right? that is suppressing your
appetite. But the problem is appetite
is not a flaw. It's a signal that you
need something. And chronic suppression
of the um of this this uh this hunger
drive, if you will, will disconnect you
from all of your internal mechanisms
that are associated with nourishment and
lack of nourishment or or eating and
stopping eating. eating and stopping
eating. The rhythm of eating and
secession of eating or eating and
non-eing is tightly regulated. If you
start to monkey around with the
chemicals that control that, you can't
help but have a problem. And there is
problems associated